conjoint ou ex conjoint après son voyage
de 113 morts celles ci sont âgées de 18
à 75 ans l'homme face à ce constat la
ville de buc en partenariat avec le
territoire départemental du grand
versailles a mis en place un atelier qui
s'inscrit dans leur accompagnement
le but créer une pièce de théâtre quand
les mots guérissent les mots objectif
redonner confiance des femmes qui se
sont révélés qu'on reprenne justement la
confiance et l'estimé d'elles-mêmes
l'une d'ailleurs n'était pas sur scène
pascal a retrouvé du travail une autre
qui a retrouvé la force d'un de pouvoir
voyager de retrouver des amis sa famille
chose qu'elle n'avait plus la force de
faire qu'elle n'osait plus faire donc
des nouvelles femmes et on voit que leur
témoignage et l'auditoire qu'on leur a
donné aujourd'hui participe aussi à la
reconstruction en cours
la représentation a pris place au
théâtre des arcades de but qu elles ont
écrit et joué leurs propres textes avec
l'aide de comédienne et d'un metteur en
scène chacune amener quelque chose de
personnel sous forme de danse théâtre ou
encore témoignages on a bien compris en
discutant a pris avec elle que en fait
ça leur avait servi aussi à passer en
fait une c
ce moment
à mettre des mots sur leurs douleurs
leurs difficultés qu'a pu connaître dans
le temps sur scène quatre femmes
objectif pour elle tourner la page mais
aussi témoigner pour toutes celles qui
subissent des violences
[Musique]
je pensais à toutes ces femmes qui
n'avaient pas eu la chance de pouvoir
s'en sortir de trouver la bonne personne
qui les aurait aidés qui auraient toutes
ces femmes qui avaient pas au fur et à
mesure des mois et des années senti la
force qu'on a tout en fait en nous mais
qu'on développe pas suffisamment parce
qu'on sait pas comment faire
et on n'ose pas le faire et je vends
jour les airs parler pour elle la ville
de buc envisage de poursuivre ce projet
par la rédaction d'une bande dessinée
le but mettre sur papier ce témoignage
est sensibilisé la ville espère
également tourné ce spectacle dans
d'autres villes des yvelines leur vie
nous nous tenons nous pour celle de huf
plus mais aussi pour celles qui ont vu
basculer leur chemin